welcome to this video playing mana era
22 that's a new opponent someone I never
played before that's a new account okay
it just has one game this somewhere in
the others so it's not necessarily a
fishy account so let's see what he's
doing there okay men playing the
classical variation yeah 25 okay go III
or Knight f3 queer the d5 line is a very
very solid one where black has very
reasonable chances of equalizing one of
the absolute main lines yep knight c6
black has a very healthy position he
gets in very often he gets an e5 and can
develop the bishop so I'm just going to
continue my own development here Queenie
for for example is a very decent move
now here he went for that um okay
cooksey one maybe I don't know exactly
what's better here taking was also an
option in both cases black as I said has
very decent chances to equalize after 94
or 95 it's difficult for me to to keep
the bishop if not impossible so I'm
going to prevent night to be form
okay maybe maybe this is this may be an
idea for me to try to play for something
yeah that is the the meat down you want
so I cannot take on hitting on c6 and
take on e5 what i can do is i can take
twice on c6 it's probably also just
equal but Luke's is 6e 494 is just good
for me still asrock v8 and a 5 it's
probably just liquidus position and it
seems like he has compensation so I'm
going like before and he has a 5 now
after which I can castle further for the
equal position interesting what is he
doing here ooh k 6 isn't this good don't
I don't get that rope t3 what is the
idea ok 6 ok after a 494 I'm actually
checkmated so that is the point
ok be 64
I wonder rookie 4 h3 if I can do that
then he has bishop CA hmm ok that's a
surprisingly tricky position
hmm
yeah probably i just said i have nothing
better than this thing which is just a
very jewish just very jewish maybe yeah
see I think he takes f 3 and a 3 now
which just looks kind of normal don't
really think he has something better
then we just have a very equal position
I go look be one and then be 5 p-6 for
the draw or something else I can't go
rook see one as well for Luke see a
check which is also very George yeah
maybe that one I'm not sure what is what
is more convincing I cannot do more than
that he's just too active them
yeah Freddie Rooke c8 made I think he he
will probably play him and move like
hair like this Shack why is he taking
time there sit again an engine jet
engine or what I don't know taking time
on those moves is really weird it's
getting really sick nowadays yeah with
the engine guys it's it's possible
because this whole thing was very very
logical let's say and I didn't really
phase anything particularly dangerous so
it's possible that I can actually have
this drawing position against the engine
quite them quite often you can simply
argue that okay if you have a draw
position against the computer or against
the suspected computer you can argue
okay it cannot be because the computer
will crush you why should you have a
drawn position but this was such a such
a non game that is actually possible
yeah I'm getting the draw here I'm in
this position quite quite easily I can
make an offer rah rah ah ok
check yeah of course I will win this I
will try to win this on time now because
of two things he declined the drawer
there which is kind of ridiculous and i
think it's an engine and if he is too
slow because he has to check every move
against against the computer that's not
my problem check alright so we have to
know actually getting the h-bond
it's still a draw though I mean he just
gave me this pawn but it's still very
dry yep i said i cannot move the age
porn easily okay now at the clock is
grandfathered okay that wasn't the best
possible moment to get to get something
delivered at you're doing okay I just
blundered this blundered this right time
morning hmm that's bad check I said
continue this I know this doesn't seem
very sportsman like but I think this is
just a computer so I'm going to impress
this on Tyra yeah you can do whatever
you want not this game because you're
cheating I simply don't buy that
multiple times for in only move
situations spending like five seconds I
jumped by that absolutely not check
yeah I know this game will will cause
some debates there in the comment
section but I don't care this is a
computer and I'm going to take this
point on time check check check black
for Fitz on time the second thing that
made me very suspicious is still I mean
it's just one or two games here yeah but
still 1,500 1100 and on five minute he's
got that and he's got very little games
in yeah we can we can check that yeah I
simply don't buy that and there are
mother of multiple occasions where there
were only moves and he simply spend ages
on them okay let's see here like four
seconds four seconds it's all coming
like clockwork but this is still this is
still theoretical moves this also after
six seconds and this is a tricky move
yeah you have to have to assess all that
again six seconds and again after couple
of seconds I cancelled and this this
took longer surprisingly and and also
here what is this what what is why do
you have to think 20 seconds here
there's so no other moves you have to
take the upon their okay but anyway and
now g6 can't hear ya like 10 seconds 10
seconds for that move check and 30
seconds for that move I don't I don't
buy that I'd simply don't buy that until
you also took long time for for very
simple moves there check yeah I would
never play that on time button under the
so those some of those circumstances how
he actually tells me to run posle if
someone is able to translate that it's
probably something very friendly but ok
I don't care I'm sorry this is me this
is the cheetah and I'm winning this on
time because he failed to me because he
spent too much time looking at his
engine all the time so if you are of
some other opinion you're welcome but
this is this is my opinion and I acted
accordingly thanks for watching